who would have thought ten years ago
when I left the mothership that rece
Davis would stop by and he came without
any PR from ESPN there's no security
here no nothing you even brought a
picture here I brought a gift oh you see
this you recognize any of these people
oh my goodness look at this what year do
you think that is so that's that's the
entire on-air staff at the mothership
there's Tirico in there doing
SportsCenter Robin Roberts is there yeah
Gary milliner Charley Steiner Stuart
Scott Rich Eisen that's a pretty Rich
Eisen with hair yeah that's a pretty
good line dan said that rich not me yeah
Linda Cohen yeah Steve Levy Gary Miller
what what year at Larry oh he's not in
the picture so what year did Keith leave
97 maybe yeah so the I mean probably
right up there 95 March of 95 oh okay I
didn't start doing Sports Center until
96 how old were you when you got there I
was 29 when I got there and 30 by the
time I finally did a Sports Center I
wanted to do SportsCenter before I
turned 30 and I missed that goal by
about a month when I was but I was on
ESPN or espn2 at 29 what do you remember
about your first SportsCenter it was
2:00 a.m. SportsCenter with Brett Hebert
and it was one of those deals I think
I've told this story publicly before
when I first got there the sports smash
in the old sports night show the Stewart
and Sue's you were doing got cancelled
he got canceled about a month after I
arrived and I hope that was coincidence
but so I did they didn't really have
anything for me to do so they were
trying to decide and I'd been instructed
I mean I was told and explicit terms do
not ask to do SportsCenter we're
creating separate identities for ESPN
and espn2 so now they don't know what
they're gonna do with me maybe they're
just gonna cut me loose so I talked them
into letting me do a Sports Center I got
a 2:00 a.m. on a Saturday night with
Brett Hebert and after after the show I
had a message light on my phone when I
went upstairs and I assume it's my
mother or my wife or something and it's
Keith and I've had one conversation with
Keith Olbermann probably the entire
eight months I'd been there and he said
you should be in the rotation
he said I'll do what I can he had no
idea that they were thinking about
cutting me loose and I've been eternally
grateful to him since then for that do
you think that you
vulnerable that they weren't gonna keep
oh sure yeah if I had not done well in
that show I think there's a really good
possibility of it because I was working
behind the scenes to get you fired well
that's not surprising because you
mentioned when we looked at this picture
no egos shuffling behind the scenes
going on there right how competitive was
it was I nice to you you actually you
were now you were at a level you and
Keith were at a level that us new guys
had to sort of prove ourselves but after
a while yeah you were you were very kind
to me you were fine especially helped me
if I wasn't hurt I would now probably
wouldn't have then for fear that then
you would have gotten me fired but I
would tell you I would say Dan you were
a jerk but you weren't no you were good
and so was Keith actually both were both
you guys were great do you got a great
story with no names attached to it a
great story with no names attached to it
after think about that for a little bit
mmm have to get ready I imagine you have
a few oh yeah now I put names on one
name on it I had been doing it I was
secure now so they weren't going to fire
me
you remember how Charlie we would give
injury reports Charley Steiner would say
you know he's day today but then again
aren't we off so one night we were doing
the 6:00 p.m. Sports Center in Charlie's
Charlie's back in his chair like this
because I'm doing whatever and I come to
somebody who's day-to-day he's not on
camera but no he's not on camera Bea's
on set well he and I are doing the sick
yeah he's off camera and I come to the
part day today so I'm trying to do a
little anchor interplay there you know
and as a you know these day-to-day but
hey Charlie then again aren't we all I
still had more to do but the director
punches up Charlie and Charlie's you
know sprawled out like this hands behind
his head and he was ripped I mean he was
pretty pissed at me after well it's
always weird there's certain guys had
chemistry with another guy's Union I had
no chemistry with Kenney maim or Stuart
Scott mm-hmm even though individually
they were very talented right I just had
no chemistry whatsoever Keith who was a
great individual talent I had chemistry
with and it didn't make any sense to
anybody
else including management that somehow
we we just it worked
mm-hmm but there are guys you work with
because people go oh you you get paired
with somebody and you go this isn't
gonna work right it but you still have
to do an hour show with them and go hey
let's just chat it up a little bit here
booyah I can remember Iowa I guess I
don't care now I'll just attach names
when Kilbourne was getting ready to go
to Comedy Central or whatever I did
several shows with him that summer
leading up and he would look at me at
the beginning and what we called the A's
now we used to call the tens you know
the first segment of the show yeah he
looked at me and say I guess I'll be
with you through the tens kid but then
I'm out he was basically putting
together a little resume reel and then
it was the rest of the show he was just
clicking time well yeah he would do the
the first part we had the juicy
highlights that's where that's where
Kilby wanted to kill it after that he
mailed it in not even not even paying
attention I wonder if they do and I in
all seriousness hey 34:39 Craig Kilborn
because where did fascinating I showed
up on a macaroni commercial recently and
I hadn't thought and he and I weren't
close at all I hadn't thought about him
in quite some time and I saw him and I
thought the same thing you'd I don't
know what happened or why he made the
choices he made or whatever but I
remember when he first got there first
day Kilbourne got there we went to what
was the what was the bar that was up
across the street bleachers yes okay so
we go to bleachers and Kilbourne goes
tell me some dirt tell me some gossip
and then you're like you just walked in
the door dude and then he goes I got
five questions for you and so he goes
yeah this Mike it's nice thing I got
five questions and I go okay so he would
always ask these five questions and then
he got to Comedy Central or his show of
following Letterman and he did his five
questions they're fascinating god yeah
extreme talent he was really talented
with NBA highlights in the Minnesota
Vikings other than that he didn't know
and didn't care but he could deliver a
line you've been to Bloomington before
just for basketball not for football
they're gonna honor Lee Corso
oh we're looking for
- looking forward to getting him back
there there was a possibility of getting
the show there on a Saturday last year
and didn't quite work out and so I'm
really glad that we're gonna go there
and open up it it's gonna be cool give
people a sense of what it's like we see
and as I told you before you're like a
duck on water you'd look like
everything's just you know I'm a traffic
cop here I'm landing planes everything's
nice it's everything's great
there's tons of noise it's chaos and you
you know Corso you don't know what's
gonna happen your guest picker comes on
there's so much involved bear you go to
for something Herbie's here what is it
like you know sort of in the moment
behind the scenes there you have to have
ultimate concentration yet awareness to
be able to react to what happens because
if something's going on either on the
set or behind you and you're oblivious
to it then the people at home are seeing
and so you've got to find a way to
incorporate it smoothly into the show
and make a snap judgment as to whether
you want to incorporate it or not so you
know there are a lot of people talking
to step but we don't script anything
there's nothing is in teleprompter or
anything like that now I write I write
leads by hand you know and and refer to
them and sort of almost as you would
speak extemporaneously but the rest of
it is just conversation and you know we
might have on some topics in order of
who's going first but once the
conversation starts it's just sort of a
free-for-all and you have to manage it
and sort of get a feel for when you need
to when you stop and move on or change
or get somebody out of hot water does
anybody tell you about a certain sign
behind yes because I can't there's no
way I can see those unless I were to
pick it up on a monitor or something so
if there's a great sign behind us our
producer Jim guy arrow or or the
director Rodney Perez or somebody will
get my ear and say hey hey there's a
sign behind you that says and then maybe
I'll reference it or maybe I won't did
it come up in meetings about Dan Patrick
show signage it did and actually so many
of the people were trying to get them
taken down but I've lobbied to increase
the number of Dan Patrick show signs
behind really know because Chris Fowler
was upset with me because will you just
tell your audience stop doing that I go
no it was fun because they were trying
to slip in those signs who cares
right there I really don't I I don't
care at all I mean I'm a company guy as
you know I've been there 22 years but if
but if your audience if they get a sign
it good for them you know good for them
we've got people patrolling this side I
know that I don't want anybody the only
thing I don't want in the signs is
anything that is you know that's
offensive yeah that's you know
over-the-top offensive do you want to
walk that line it's okay but
over-the-top offensive and maybe like
there was a there was a sexual innuendo
which I didn't realize was just that
that that I actually referenced on the
side and I I didn't know I know I didn't
know the reference and I did play after
yeah well no I never knew until somebody
told me later and I was like oh there's
a name for that if you'd like to show up
and get on camera with the DP show sign
Reese is encouraging you have to go to
Bloomington Ohio State against Indiana
Thursday August 31st what did you make
of the poll that Saban and Harbaugh two
most overrated coaches in America
preposterous for save and I I heard I
saw the one coach anonymously who said
you know you go to battle and I've got a
squirt gun and he's got a howitzer and
you went and we say you're great
well guess what when he took over that
job people were saying that they could
never restore greatness in Alabama at
the time had passed
who did that yeah he did it's a it's a
stupid thing to say and it's a jealous
thing to say and with Harbaugh he took
over Stanford and they were like 111 who
even San Diego Alfred yeah he won at San
Diego he fixed Stanford and he's in the
process of fixing Michigan no by the way
almost won the Super Bowl and it's it's
ludicrous that that anybody would say
that I think because jealousy the
storyline in college football this year
is what or who probably the year of the
quarterback I think we've had
quarterback play that hasn't been great
and is there a quarterback like a
deshaun Watson that can elevate his team
is it is it Sam Darnell is it DeAndre
Francois is jaylen hurts improved enough
to be able to give Alabama championship
I think that that's the those are the
biggest storylines that and everybody's
even though Clemson's the reigning
champion everyone
sort of chasing Alabama I think because
of this decade of dominance they've had
and that's why that first weekend game I
think is is so huge it sort of
establishes a little bit of a pecking
order what do you think of jumping into
the season like that with Alabama you
know when you're playing Florida State
you got everybody's attention there as
opposed to easing in against Wabash I
think it's great for the sport but maybe
not for the team or for every team it
would probably benefit all of them to
play Wabash or Quinnipiac or somebody
and and sort of ease into it the way you
would a preseason game in the NFL for
the sport and for the attention
certainly for us it's great to have
Alabama Florida State in UCLA Texas A&M
and Florida Michigan which we'll have on
our air Saturday as well Tennessee
Georgia Tech on Labor Day night games
like that to start the season are great
for the sport great for the product and
great for us but an individual team
would probably benefit by playing you
know a virtual exhibition game to start
sneaky teams that you like this year I
think TCU because they rarely have two
bad years and robe their schedules a
little tough I don't know if Oklahoma
State qualifies to be sneaked certainly
sounds like there's some big
expectations there are starting to grow
they've got a terrific quarterback
they've got an explosive wide receiver
who says he's not hurt although there
have been some rumors around how healthy
James Washington is he says he's fine
I think those are two for sure and if
Florida or Miami can solve their
quarterback issues or answer their
quarterback questions positively both of
those teams could be really good I think
coaches on the hot seat I think you'll
the first weekend you'll see UCLA in
Texas A&M and whoever loses that game
their coaches their fans are not going
to be happy
UCLA with the way it fell off the map
last year with Jim Mora and Kevin Sumlin
probably the I mean I Kevin's a friend
of mine I think he's a really good coach
but probably the Johnny Manziel thing as
great as it was has also made it tougher
for him because now they've had trouble
finding a quarterback to follow him and
as a result they lose four or five games
every year so I think I think that games
really important and then you know the
athletic director Scott would produce a
terrific guy and a great administrator
but he stated the obvious
Kevin someone knows he's got to win
so I think I think those are two to
start with for sure you look at these
teams you've covered college football
for quite some time
assess these quarterbacks in the NFL
these rookie quarterbacks that you may
have seen during the season whether in
person or you guys discussed on the show
you mean the guys they're rookies DeSean
well someone Kaiser I think Watson
particularly is a guy that that has the
it factor he people are drawn to him
I've been of covered Clemson I've done
their games I've been through their
practices players respond to him you
can't always sort like the chemistry you
were talking about on the set sometimes
you can't always evaluate exactly why it
happens but it does with DeSean and he's
a terrific guy terrific leader he's
genuine I think he's he's a really good
athlete he's got plenty of arm I think
he's going to be a very good NFL
quarterback is he gonna be a superstar
I don't know I mean that's hard to tell
because sometimes you think they will
and they won't but I think he'll be an
excellent quarterback
Travis Keyes performance has surprised
me early on at least because I still
kept saying but they tried to let him
beat out Marquess Williams for two years
at North Carolina he didn't what what's
up it but he's certainly talented yeah
it's strange when you're looking at
these kids because I loved mahomes but I
loved mahomes in his college offense I
didn't know if that would translate
transfer into the NFL but it feels like
it has they went up to get him having an
established quarterback like Alex Smith
the timeframe for him to get into the
lineup is probably a year it feels like
you know I don't know if Watson is gonna
get in this year DeSean Kaiser may be
your starting quarterback there in
Cleveland yeah
Mitchell true Biscay trying to push you
know what's going on with Glen in there
you didn't have a franchise quarterback
but if you have quarterbacks who look
like they're on the verge of starting in
the NFL yeah and I think it's hard to
find in college because of the nature of
the offenses and you don't have as many
guys throwing with anticipation which is
something you have to do in the NFL as
you know and then the windows are even
smaller I think like that's why I like
darn 'old because Donald reminds me not
in not in the way place all the times
but in terms of throwing with
anticipation he reminds me of Andrew
Luck when he was at Stan
not many guys do that because you don't
see as many pro-style offense you see
guys throwing too big windows and wide
open spots off of read-option and that
doesn't translate to the NFL as easily
and that's that's time mahomes I just
remember watching the game against I
think Oklahoma State it was crazy
yeah yeah at the game yes Oklahoma's
like 66 like I said to the Danette site
I said you know we always just tweet out
the channel we're watching yeah and I'll
just say you know channel 604 or
something or whatever and then these
guys know tune in what are you watching
and I just saw him just lighting up
these defenses he's got he's got
tremendous physical skills he's not
afraid he's not he just he hasn't just
there's Favre in him yes which is good
and bad yeah yeah but that arm is strong
he's not afraid and it's not always
going to take the check down right where
is the place you've been that you got
nervous on College GameDay I don't think
intensity scared no crowd no not at all
I mean maybe that's dumb maybe I should
but but I don't I always feel that
little surge of adrenaline when I walk
up those steps and usually course those
already out there and he's holding up
the one helmet and they go yeah and he
holds up the other and they go boo and
he does the whole thing and there's a
surge of adrenaline I get but I don't I
haven't ever felt uneasy or nervous or
anything like that how do you explain
course oh he's a phenomenon yeah but
he's the most important part of the show
and it's because it's it's because he
genuinely cares about the show the
people he's on the set with and the
sport and it's obvious to people who are
watching at home and I think that some
of that chemistry and one of the reasons
that that I feel like that I've been
able to step into Chris's shoes and
hopefully it's gone gone well seems to
have gone well as I try to be humble and
it's very difficult for me to be humble
when I compliment yeah you know some
people say who's the guy who used to do
College GameDay that's what I say all
the time but but I think the reason
we've been able to do that is because of
Leigh Leigh's very generous cares about
show everybody cares about him you want
to make sure that he's in the best
possible situation and he wants to make
sure that that he brings it particularly
in that pic segment because it almost
feels like a college football Saturday
can't start until Lee puts on that
headgear and then it's like okay now we
can play yeah hit the microphone but now
we can play and then you got Herbie and
Desmond who we have Ohio State in
Michigan you have the relationship there
and and you know there's a there's a
family feel to it when you're tuning
into it which is what people want you
know they they know who it is they know
what to expect they're still some
surprises so it's a credit to you guys
but Congrats
you know I I meant what I've said even
when you you know I have talked about
you you haven't even been here but you
you're a good guy and you've done great
work in this business it's you're not
you usually don't get both I appreciate
that you know what real quick thing is I
throw the compliment in the bookcase
back to you a lot of times especially
when you were when you're still working
with us people would call me they would
say you know young kids trying to get
the business and they would say what
what should I do and I said the first
thing you should do is watch dan Patrick
I said now don't you know don't try to
do and you know and I'm not saying the
catchphrases and things like that so
watch the way he does his job
I said that's that's the textbook I
still think that you're you're doing
terrific and you've got the the best man
cave I've ever seen here what do you
think I think it's awesome my man my man
pearl back there has been has been
saying that he was gonna bring me bring
me in and show me around so how this
happened yeah it worked actually lovin I
didn't know that you set up this
restatements well you know we were gonna
go to lunch and I said I'd shown the man
cave and it just worked out that he
could come out with you as well
that's really nice well if you want to
leave now and go have lunch with Rhys
you can McLovin go ahead yeah actually
that sounds lovely
yeah we agree that's great I'm really
trying hard but nobody's jumping on the
Pearl thing I know I know I slipped Rhys
five bucks to call me pearl and it just
it's not sticking it's not working do
they miss Fritzi who yeah that's what I
thought Fritzi I'm kidding we love you
we miss you but you're not welcome back
rhys-davies you can see him a couple
times here coming up really soon it'll
be Ohio State at Indiana Thursday August
first and then in Atlanta Florida state
Alabama September first briefs it's time
to say Reece out oh thanks for stopping
by
you bet dad next after this the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience